Matte next to shine creates
something really special
to look at.
Look at me?
Gorgeous.
I'm Sir John.
And in the next 30 days, you'll
learn the exact techniques
I use on my celebrity clients.
I'm going to demo
three looks that
are going to rock your
world-- the Everyday Look,
the No-Makeup Makeup Look,
and the Icon.
We're going to dive into my
makeup kit, step-by-step.
I'll show you what to buy, what
to keep, what to throw away.
You don't need to know
anything about makeup
to take this class.
Skin is skin.
And that is genderless.
It's ageless.
It's timeless.
Let's do it.
No-Makeup makeup is all
about just adding definition,
using minimal products.
I always work from
my hand because I
don't want to pour all of
my money into the sponge.
You want it to go
directly onto the skin.
Around the eyes, always
use your ring finger.
It's the weakest
finger you have.
Think about tapping
and not just rubbing.
Super excited to show
you my Everyday look.
Layering is key.
I like to use cream, and
I set it with a powder.
That creates a face that will
last you all day, all night.
Always keep a couple brushes
that have no product on them
as little magic erasers.
I've had some of these
brushes since I was 19.
If these brushes could talk,
they would need an NDA.
I want to show you
how much fun you
can have with light reflection,
with depositing color
for smoky eyes.
Start small and then
blow out the color.
Apply a little cream blush
into the crease of the lid.
This is for someone
who loves glam.
My first memories with makeup
was going to be my mom.
I just remember her always
applying mascara or a lip,
and it changed her mood.
There was a little bit
more of a pep in her step
after she had a minute to
give herself self care.
I don't want you to look
at anything here as a mask.
But how can I uncover?
How can I reveal more of who
I am or who I want to be?
The most impactful
thing you can do
is to really love and be
connected to whoever you're
looking at in the mirror.
And then a lipstick helps.
I'm Sir John and
this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]